[Music]
we all believe we've run into the
burning building but until we feel that
heat we can never know
you do you chose to tie instead of
giving up your colleagues
[Music]
that test you passed
not everybody does
welcome to the afterlife
[Music]
to do what I do I need some idea of the
threatening face as I understand it
we are trying to prevent World War 3
nuclear holocaust
something was
all I have for you is the word tenant it
will open the right doors some of the
wrong ones too
I have to start looking at the weather
in a new way
I'm trying to understand it feel it has
it happened yet
[Music]
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
[Music]
his exploits are legendary what he has
to teach you may very well mean the
difference between life and death your
reputation precedes you
after admit I wasn't expecting an
invitation back they're called orders
maverick
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking
today's exercise is dogfighting
two-person what hey you've got to be
kidding
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I tell people my sister moved out west
their science teacher your husband he
renovate houses you're thinking about
moving but you're gonna waits until the
interest rates go down that's all my
story before it was an Avenger
I mean mistakes
[Applause]
and a lot of enemies
it's called Symes taskmaster he controls
the Red Room their manipulative fully
conscious but no choices
I should have come back for you how did
the others are there enough
[Applause]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're Emily fight with you
you won't win of course something
let's look into the past
okay you go to plan what shall I just
say Doug encode my plan was to drive us
away blaring a plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
I think the world wants you to be who
you are
and me my choice
I need done running
[Music]
here's what's gonna happen Natasha don't
slouch I'm not slouching you're gonna
get the back hunched listen to mother oh
my god
all right enough all of you I didn't say
anything that's not fair my life hasn't
been what you probably think it has we
all have our struggles have you ever
been left a long long time ago you so
many times
yeah all the time
[Music]
welcome to the future
life is good but it can be better
why shouldn't it be all you need to what
think about finally having everything
you always wanted
I can see today
I take what I want in return
everyone will see
[Applause]
I'll need you
you know you need to do
[Music]
nothing good is born from lies
and greatness is not what you think
[Music]
Oh dad
that just is trash it's just a trash
yeah yeah yeah 500 years
nobody's ever escaped in the going
anywhere
it's the tower so stupid
what's your name
ten-nine I owe you my life I'm going
east my way is filled with dangers come
with me
my journey follows the Silk Road
the Great Wall of China something is
very wrong
[Music]
gather the people immediately make
everyone see that the
I must help save them
I've been waiting for this for a long
time
no don't touch this this is the helmet
of Genghis Khan he'll burn this is an
instant spark
when I have the seal of the Dragon I
will rule the world
[Music]
you don't pay that this way what's the
last thing you remember Danny he said we
had to round the reason you survived
it's because you're a very uncommon girl
you're not alone not anymore
do you know a mutants are would anyone
like you she had their first time brain
I was 13 I thought it was a dream I just
lost control
Sam I started panicking people got hurt
Roberto my girlfriend and partner
Giuliana
I killed 18 men one by
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
[Music]
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
I saw something I don't think you wanted
me to see
[Music]
I don't think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear
it makes her live through it until it
kills you he's there we can get out of
this together
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dear Lord that your only angel be with
me
into your hands I commend myself my body
and soul
congratulations on your command
you'll always be looking for you leaving
even if I'm a thousand miles away
Paris gourds a greyhound you'll help me
out of a range of air cover for the next
five days I'm safe travels to England
now many crossings disis make this is my
face I got some most like they you both
kill distress rockets sir
we hits directly from the convoy
[Music]
eight hours we've lost seven ships
diesels what you did yesterday gotta
split today
not nearly enough
[Music]
Chagas disappeared sir
[Applause]
they come what are we gonna do will rain
hell down from on high
[Music]
[Music]
Mondays my right show don't have a good
day
have a great day hey bud you ever think
that there's got to be more more than
what stuff we do it day after day being
shot at run over taken hostage today's
gonna be different
hi this isn't you you don't do this man
Gary he's just resting
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
is this what recreational drugs feel
like guy this world it's a video game
and it's full of bad guys I'm a
rule-breaker I'm a rattlesnake guy we
need you to be good good guy
giddyup
is that a Glock in your pocket know what
it's two clocks
[Music]
I'm not gonna be the good guy I'm gonna
be the great guy okay
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity there you go this will not be
a war of heroes
which is all to see this is going to be
fun the world burns you have no idea of
what men are capable of
we must do something I know you want to
fight
but there are other ways of doing your
duty you're going to need a suit come on
we are the first independent
intelligence agency preserving peace and
protecting life welcome to the
like witches at black masses while
government's wait for orders our people
take action now it's time to shuttle one
[Music]
captain structure
oh my
[Music]
our enemies think we are gentlemen
but reputation is what people think of
you
character is what you are
oh great yes
[Music]
but ready we shall see
this is called a parachute it means that
one can jump out of a plane safely
[Music]
[Applause]
clothes organics six of our northern
cities have fallen in a coordinated
attack their leader fights alongside of
which
crush these murderers your majesty every
family must contribute one not to fight
your war hero you've already made many
great sacrifices
my father cannot fight so I will take
his place the northern invaders will
kill her if I expose how power all
people will kill her when we take the
Imperial City I will take revenge for my
father what is your name soldier
Wai ghin commander Sona Kajal you will
now take the oath of the warrior
wait
[Music]
release
[Music]
by pretending to be something you're not
yet here I stand proof that there is a
place for people like us
a girl threatens our plants
a warrior
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Michael I've learned you since you were
a child you have a gift
you always have if there's an answer to
no disease we'll find it
I should have died years ago
why am I still here if not to fix this
I have a rare blood disease and I'm
running out of time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it
that's not exactly gleeful
I want to see you get hurt more than you
already have this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
I went from time
increased strength his feed
echolocation
and then overpowering nerds to consume
blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
Michael Morbius I tired of doing the old
good guy thing huh what's up doc
[Music]
so what are you doing out here there is
a legend in the jungles of the Amazon of
a tree that heals or it could change the
world but if it gets into the wrong
hands it could awaken a great evil
I believe that the legend is real which
was man I'm gonna find it you are when I
do
just imagine the lives that could be
saved I've been looking for this tree
longer than anybody I've tracked the
legend to every village every island
searching for something it can't be
found but you've never had the key let's
do something that's safe let's go see
some elephants there are no elephants in
the Amazon I don't even like elephants
lady everybody likes Elvis
know this about the jungle
everything that you see wants to kill
you and can
careful take a smell fear
oh my god
who brings a submarine to the Amazon oh
yeah
[Music]
goodnight
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
forget it come on okay I don't got it
[Music]
what are you doing here in Somerville
anyway honestly my mom won't say it but
we're completely broke any honest thing
that's left in our name this is creepy
old farmhouse my grandfather left us in
the middle of nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value what is that somehow the town that
isn't anywhere near a tectonic plate
that has no fault lines no fracking no
loud music even is shaking on a daily
basis
I remember that one summer we died under
our table I found this in my living room
chiller replica a replica of what a
ghost trap there hasn't been a ghost
sighting in 30 years New York in the 80s
it's like The Walking Dead your dad
never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom my grandfather died my
mom says we're just here to pick through
the rubble of his life
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it a
[Music]
call it lock
call it karma
I believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a Connor seat
[Music]
[Music]